conan here you know i want to say i'm
very excited to announce that team coco
has partnered up with our friends
at e-league on tbs for a new e-sports
show called
rec league where we force professional
gamers to compete in video games that
are completely
ridiculous hosted by comedians orlando
laba and for a shaw
the first episode features pro gamers
golden glue and alpha rad
going head-to-head in the high-stakes
world of bus simulator 18.
that's right we're making them compete
to see who's better
at driving a realistic digital bus
around a fake video game town
yes the world's collapsing in on itself
the first episode of rec league airs
this friday night at midnight as part of
the tbs show
super punch may the best simulated bus
driver win check it out look
i've honestly done an incredible job i
haven't even hit a car
this run it's been insane i mean i might
just do it just for fun you know just
feel something
all right there we go sorry it just
didn't feel right otherwise saturday
i do love how this bus is so good at
pushing all other cars out of the way
what stop are you at stop
it's cute it's really cute